how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and
right now one of the biggest questions
out there that has not been answered yet
is will black widow and other future
marvel movies go
straight to disney plus as premier
access or are we finally going to be
getting a theatrical release for them
now we really don't have to worry about
other movies such as the eternals or
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness or spider-man 3.
it's mainly just black widow that pretty
much a lot of the fan base at this point
in time right now are saying just
release it on disney plus so we can at
least see it
yes everybody believes that it deserves
a theatrical release but as of right now
we don't know if that will ever happen
over the weekend we got some news from
disney's ceo
and executive vice president that lead
us to believe that they may be
considering releasing black widow on
disney plus
and an announcement for it could be
coming very soon
so i'll break down what they said but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all of the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a tony stark funko pop i'm picking a
winner on friday
and thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video more on them later
on
so this past thursday disney's new ceo
bob chapack
hinted to wall street analysts during an
interview that disney is set to get more
aggressive in offering some
new theatrical titles via disney plus
paid download as it did in september
with mulan and as it's about to do with
disney's soul with many of the us
theaters shut down because of the
coronavirus disney made mulan available
on disney plus for
29.99 launching on their video on demand
service which they called premier access
and
on thursday bob chapek said that there
was enough traction with the premier
access release of mulan to encourage
them to do
more in this vein and then he said
something that was very very interesting
now there was a lot of controversy
around mulan about where they filmed the
movie
the controversy happened after the
release of mulan on disney plus and bob
chapek acknowledged that the controversy
did in fact hurt the film
and when he commented on it he said we
saw enough
very positive results before that
controversy started
we've got something there in terms of
the premier access strategy and then he
said that he has more details to come
on december 10th when disney holds an
investor day presentation
on its streaming strategy now a lot of
people are thinking that this could be
the announcement of black widow coming
to disney plus's premier
access after all very recently disney
and marvel studios did say that they are
taking the necessary precautions during
this pandemic
and the reshuffling of the schedule of
marvel's phase 4 to make sure that the
mcu keeps its continuity and everything
flows
and to make sure that there are no
spoilers with anything that comes out
originally black widow was supposed to
be the first film released followed by
the falcon and the winter soldier the
eternals shang chi
and then one division but as of right
now one division is going to be the
first mcu phase 4 project released in
january of 2021
most likely followed by the falcon and
the winter soldier and then black widow
so the order is off but marvel studios
assures us that they're going to make
sure there are no spoilers
but as i mentioned marvel studios
executive vice president victoria alonso
was recently asked in an interview about
whether or not black widow is going to
go to disney plus premier access or not
and she ended it on a very interesting
note but this is what she had to say in
the interview
it seems to me that our films are films
for theatrical distribution
we always said that we believe in
different formats and it's very
important to maintain the custom
the tradition of watching certain films
and community
with avengers in-game we did as usual
every friday before a movie comes out we
go to see it with people who had never
seen it
if you see it with those 500 people or
the thousand people or the 100 people
who were in the cinema
what you feel when you see that movie
with other people is something very
different from what one can feel in the
living room with the four
five or six people who live in your
house so whenever possible and that is
something that health measures
allow us we want our films to be seen in
the cinema
now i think most would agree that if we
had our preference yes we would see
black widows in theaters
granted health measures allow us to as
victoria alonso mentioned the experience
is definitely way different and usually
much better in the theater
however it doesn't really seem like we
have that option and it doesn't really
seem like we're going to have it anytime
soon
states are having shutdowns again and it
seems like many more are about to join
them as well
and that's where that last line of this
interview comes in where she said
so whenever possible and that is
something that health measures allow us
we want our films to be seen in the
cinema well right now
it doesn't seem like health measures are
making it possible
it really doesn't seem possible right
now that black widow can be released in
theaters and actually perform well
and in fact there's a lot of talk right
now about wonder woman 1984 being
released on hbo max
and that is because warner brothers
feels like it may perform better on hbo
max than in the theaters due to all the
recent states that have had to shut down
again
and as bob chapeck said mulan performed
very well
even despite the controversy and he said
that they're going to talk about it more
on december 10th during investors day
where we could be getting an
announcement for black widow to be
released on disney plus's premiere
access
and hopefully on investors they will be
getting a little bit more than just
talk about whether or not black widow is
going to go on premiere access and i'll
talk about that in just a second but
first
big thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
skillshare has been my go-to this past
year through the pandemic for learning
new skills
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
i have personally used skillshare to try
and get better at youtube i've watched
videos on photoshop how to edit better
and i've watched editorial videos on how
to edit my videos better as well
and as i mentioned before i've also been
using it during quarantine to try and
get better at guitar taking classes
i know a lot of people have asked me how
to start a youtube channel how to get
better at youtube while skillshare is
the perfect place to learn all of those
things
and the great news is is that the first
thousand of my subscribers to click on
this link in the description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium so you
can explore your creativity and if
you're not one of the first thousands
don't worry it's only ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription so
it's very
very affordable if you're interested in
youtube classes you can check out the
teacher sorel amore
just click the link in the description
down below to get started
now we could be getting a black widow
disney plus premier access announcement
but hopefully we might get a little bit
of a teaser for what's to come to disney
plus as well
perhaps something like the teaser
trailer for the falcon and the winter
soldier now disney has shown teaser
trailers before
at an investor's day and they have
actually revealed titles before
of new marvel studios disney plus
projects so hopefully on this
investors day we can get a little bit
more information on what marvel studios
is planning as far as black widow and
hopefully we can get at least a little
bit of a teaser for the falcon in the
winter soldier
or something else that'll help us in
this year where we got no new marvel
content the right way
and i'll be sure to keep you up to date
on anything i hear so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
thank you to heroes hideout.com for
providing the tony stark funko pop and
you can check them out for other awesome
marvel merch don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you